this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
good afternoon for those of you who
don't know me my name is Michael
Bernstein I'm an assistant professor
here in the HCI group in the computer
science department and i'm here to
introduce kate starboard of the many
people who have visited this seminar
with wikipedia pages kate may be the
only one whose page starts with the fact
that she was in a WNBA star kate went
and did her PhD in colorado working on
crisis informatics being one of a small
group of people who really pushed this
to the forefront of sort of the study of
how people deal with large-scale
disasters and especially as it
intersects with how technology mediates
that and how social media comes into
play she's now just beginning her first
quarter as a professor in the human
centered design and engineering program
at the University of Washington so we're
really lucky that we can get her here
roughly two weeks after she started
teaching and after this I'll give it
away to Kate thanks thank you Michael he
didn't they also mention that it is my
reunion year and I was looking for a
good reason to come back in town and
this is there's no better year than
they're doing better reason than to come
talk to you guys so I'm going to give a
talk here that covers a lot of the
research that I did for my PhD and then
I'll talk a little bit about some of the
future directions that I am working on
the talk is called crowd work crisis and
convergence unpacking crowd source in
the context of mass disruption events as
Michael said the area that I've been
working on is broadly speaking crisis
informatics is broadly defined as sort
of examining the social and technical
aspects of ICT use during crises and I
was very fortunate to be working at the
University of Colorado with laceup Palin
who was one of two people that actually
coined this crisis informatics term and
has been looking at this area for
several years now and has a very nice
NSF project called Project epic which
stands for empowering the public with
information during crisis so a lot of
the work i'll be talking about was done
in collaboration with colleagues there
at the university of colorado i like to
talk about what i do is sort of this
combination of social computing and mass
disruption events so my work is at the
intersection of these two social
computing being like
social media and other CMC I look at the
collaboration and interaction that these
tools enable often on a massive scale
and I look at that in the context of
mass disruption events and mass
disruption is a term we're using to to
cover events that caused major
disruption to the normal social routines
so events like disasters natural and
man-made as well as maybe mass mass
emergencies extreme weather events and
also political protests and so one of
the interesting things we've been seeing
in recent years is these mass disruption
events have become mass convergence
events online where a lot of people come
to participate what's interesting is in
the crisis in the crisis context this
isn't actually anything new sociologists
have disaster have long known that after
a disaster event people will converge
physically onto the scene to try to
offer help among other things they
actually come for a lot of different
reasons and they've been called
spontaneous volunteers so there's this
this ethic of spontaneous volunteers and
that's that's always sort of happened in
the context of mass disruption events or
as long as we've been studying and
studying it in weeping sociologists a
disaster so what I've been seeing is
that people are now using social media
to converge and I'm sure you all kind of
have a good picture of what that means
but just to give you a few numbers after
the 2010 haiti earthquake twitter was
actually pretty young back then project
epic collected over three million tweets
we had from over 800,000 different
Twitterers this is the first two weeks
after the event a year later after the
japan earthquake there were like dozens
of facebook posts per second Twitter use
was even higher and just in a small
event last year probably very few people
even notice it was happening that I was
collecting on some US tornadoes and I
was getting 800 tweets per minute and so
just even small events now are
generating a ton a ton of information
and there's a lot of opportunities for
those digital convergence things we
could can do now that we couldn't do
before so with citizen reporting we have
this capability for people on the ground
during event to use their mobile phones
or or maybe they're still online to
communicate and share information about
what they're seeing and what's HAP
with the the larger crowd with with
maybe their peers maybe emergency
responders in a new way so people are
suddenly unable to be sensors and
reporters of what's going on there's
also possibilities for digital for
formal responders to use use these tools
to communicate to people that are
affected by a disaster so they can use
them as a crisis communication channel
there's also a lot of challenges with
this digital conversion so just to name
a few we've got this huge volume of
information and it's hard to just wade
through it even if all of it was good
and it turns out not very much of it is
interesting so most of the volume is
noise so if we're looking for
information coming from the ground that
could help us get a better situational
awareness of what's going on well we
really don't care about you know all
these people out in the crowd or
retweeting things or saying you know we
support the people we want them to feel
better but you know doesn't really help
us get the information from the crowd so
there's a lot of just noise that we have
to wade through there's also a problem
of lost context which is particularly
particularly particularly tough for
platforms like Twitter where information
actually loses the connection between
who initially created it and what time
it was created and so if you can imagine
a tweet that says you need to you might
need to evacuate we have a voluntary
evacuation at 4pm and someone tweets
that out at 8pm well it actually could
be very bad information the evacuation
could be mandatory by then so you've got
this this problem with the information
propagation that that things can get
lost and we also have related to that
misinformation disinformation people
bloating bed in for information into the
system whether on purpose or not and
that information spreading another
problem is the unstructured data nature
of social media data I do a lot of work
on Twitter but I think this is true of
most platforms is that the information
isn't in a way isn't in a structure that
we can easily collect it aggregate it
categorize it process it and things like
that so so there's all these sort of
issues that are interesting to look at
and so I guess when I entered the space
and I have so
an engineer background I'm like well how
do we solve the problem how do we get
you so how do we extract useful
information from from all these social
media platforms and and make them into
useful resources that people can use to
help them make informed decisions during
disaster events and to give away a lot
from the beginning here what what I
ended up finding that there's
technically the problem is very hard but
that the crowd is already working in
many ways to help organize this
information and they're doing that in a
variety of different capacities one is
its digital volunteers where people in
the remote crowd actually are
intentionally trying to help structure
information filter information pass
information on to people who can use it
we've got emergent response
organizations where digital volunteers
are starting to work together and i'll
talk about this a lot state form
organizations that that help the process
information and move it around some of
these groups are becoming ongoing
virtual volunteer organizations they're
even becoming NGOs now we're there they
intend to keep responding to different
crisis events in different ways to help
process information during disasters and
another way that people are working is
well if you switch perspective you can
actually see like all of the activity of
the crowd in some ways helps to organize
it and we can actually leverage some of
that ambient activity all of those
retweets are the follows during an event
on Twitter or connections new
connections being made on facebook maybe
to help identify information interesting
information during events so I'm going
to talk about this as crowd work I'm
actually going to resist a term
crowdsourcing initially I thought my
research was crowdsourcing and the more
and more I looked into it the more I
kept seeing my my research fall a little
bit outside of the crowdsourcing term so
I'm going to critique the term a little
bit show you where my work doesn't quite
fit and another thing related to that
every time I say this to someone from
the social sciences they'll say well
what do you mean by a crowd and I think
that's an interesting an interesting
question always to start out when you're
thinking about a crowdsourcing platform
or anything and so what I mean that by a
crowd is not necessarily a crowd of
number a lot of the activities I see are
small
two people 20 people to people there are
also great great big groups of people we
can use the actions of hundreds of
thousands of people to to get
information so what I mean by
crowdedness it not necessarily size
although it's the potential of size so
it's the potential to find people that
can help but also for me the crowd and I
don't think this is true of all
crowdsourcing for me the crowd is often
the audience the other event so the
convergent audience of people that want
to participate because they're
interested in an event they come
together and for me that that changes
some of the motivations for why the
crowd is there during disaster events
and it has it speaks to some of the
interesting things that I see so I'm
going to cover a few studies that we've
done on crowd work that I was involved
with that epic and I will start again
from from my silly little question where
I was going to change the world so how
do i extract useful information from
social media updates and initially and
often we've concentrated on Twitter and
it's not just because I'm a huge Twitter
fan i became a Twitter fan afterwards
but initially it wasn't on Twitter
myself when I started their research but
it has some affordances that make it
valuable in the crisis context useful
for researchers and which is a nice
combination and also useful for people
trying to build tools so twitter has its
everything in Twitter or not everything
but almost everything is public which
and it's searchable which means if you
can tap into the api's you can you can
pull it so unlike Facebook where people
have privacy connections and people
can't see the information and Twitter
when you get an account you know that
all your information is going to be
public and so for that reason it
actually has seen some interesting
adoption and Crichton a crisis context a
lot of the emergency response managers I
know who are moving into social media
think of Twitter as their major platform
because it's something that they could
actually talk talk with their
constituents or they're the people they
work for as well as get information from
the crowd so that's I'm not going to
give you I'm going to assume that
everyone here knows some of the
underlying things of Twitter if you
don't most of this will make sense you
might be lost a little bit but well
initially try to do is say how can we
take tweets and process them categorize
the map then figure out what's
interesting about them during a disaster
event and help like make the information
useful in a lot of an epic sexually a
big project there were 20 25 researchers
on the project and a lot of them are
looking at natural language processing
strategies and I was in on the
conversations and I was listening and I
could tell it was really really really
hard and it was it was hard in a sense
that they still had to figure out how to
do it it was hard as in a sense that
their best that they were going to do
was about eighty to eighty-five percent
in terms of accuracy of what they could
do and they weren't even close to being
there yet and so so I thought well maybe
there are different strategies for
helping to helping to process this
information and like the good young
researcher I was of just oh there's
simple solution and I thought well why
don't we just shift the burden of
interpretation from machines to people
and have people put their information
and tweets in a way that makes it
machine readable and if we were going to
do that how could we do that so I was
actually at that becomes that idea
becomes the the beginning of the tweak
the tweet project which is sort of the
launching point into this research but I
was at a random hacks of kindness
hackathon in the crisis space it was
actually the first one they've gone on
to have many of these now and I was
working with another researcher there
and I came up with this idea of using a
hash tag based syntax so basically
leveraging what people were already
using or what they already knew about
the hashtag and using a hash tag based
syntax to have people mark up their
tweets in a way that we could get
information from it and so the goal of
it really simply we were asking them to
put certain hashtags in certain places
to tell basically tell a computer what
they were talking about so we could
easily classify this tweet as a need we
could see what they was needed we've got
a location information that we could
send to a mapping mapping tool and
contact information and other things
they could mark it up with with several
different ways so basically what we
tried to do was teach people to make
their tweets machine readable and our
idea for for doing this was we would use
prescriptive tweeting and we would send
it out in the space and somehow people
would get the message that they could
put their information in this way and
they would do it they would be able to
report what was going on from the ground
very simplistic I'll tell you what we
learned about that late
her but we did end up building i built
an infrastructure pretty lightweight to
make that work where I would do some
collect tweets process them get some
geolocation information I would put it I
would put the process information on
like a spreadsheet so people could see
what was going on and then we would
eventually we mapped them so people
could see we would met them and color
them by what they were categorized in
things these crisis maps have been
become popular when I built the
infrastructure I was basically just
trying to show proof of concept because
I was more interested in the data than
the tools but for some reason the public
likes this either information going into
maps but we're not yet sure if
responders can use those maps um so
anyways we built the infrastructure we
end up launching tweaked the tweet for
over 30 events between 2009-2011 not
going to talk about all of them I have
learned some interesting things I'm not
sure if the project keeps going but I
keep intending to stop it but keeping
people keep pulling me back into it to
do it again so I might have to set up
the infrastructure to make it work
without me um I'll put that on my list
of things to do but it was there our
first our first deployment of this where
we really well we learned a lesson that
we kept learning over and over again but
it turns out to be pretty fascinating so
I'm going to concentrate on that here so
the haiti earthquake was a massive
earthquake that hit haiti in 12th of
january two thousand ten it caused
catastrophic damage it had afterwards
there was a huge humanitarian need and
it took weeks for humanitarian response
to really that week sits there still
trying to get a picture of what's going
on there haiti is interesting it is
actually been noted by many as a as
marking a turn in the realization by the
humanitarian response that they had to
consider social media data and that
there was this thing called digital
volunteerism so the event itself was the
first time where digital volunteers
crowd activity and social media activity
came to the surface enough that
humanitarian response was like oh this
is something we might we might need to
deal with you
there are things about some of this
behavior had already been going on there
were things about the event haiti was a
huge event it was very close to the US
so people were connected to it and
interesting in interesting ways there
was a lot of media attention there
people could feel it this early so they
were interested in it and I think that
caused some of the extra attention at
the same time Twitter was just becoming
something that was popular not there
enough users there that we could see
some of that behavior and also the usual
ed platform put down a crisis mapping
instance we'll talk about way later in
this talk where they were mapping SMS
messages from the ground and Haiti and
telling the responders they could look
at and responders didn't know what to do
with it yet so there's an interesting if
anyone's really interested in this
there's a report called the disaster two
point O relief report and that talks
about the problems the humanitarian
responders had in dealing with the data
so we we had not quite fleshed out
tweaked the tweet we had actually come
up with it in this community of other
technicians in crises and with that
community was called crisis comments we
decided to deploy tweaked the tweet on
january fourteenth actually at the time
not thinking that people on the ground
would be using it we actually didn't
knew that that people in haiti weren't
using twitter they're out there there
are many users there now but there
weren't many there but we thought maybe
responders could use it to help
communicate when they got there we
learned a lot of lessons about that so
I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about how that deployment went so we
ended up we deployed it we sent
thousands of prescriptive tweet messages
out there and in the end we collect the
data of anyone who sent a tweet tweet so
anyone whoever sent the tweet tweet
weather is a retweet or they send it
directly we identified them and captured
all their tweets during the event and we
went through and did an analysis and we
found that four people sent tweet tweets
from the ground they sent a total of ten
tweets with their needs i need water or
something else and not surprisingly
although this won't yeah this won't
surprise anyone it's really hard to
teach people that
I can tweet like a computer especially
people that are affected at the time but
what was interesting was we found 74
people in the crowd who translated
information into the syntax and so they
would take information they were finding
elsewhere like this College on June was
on the ground and he was tweeting
constantly about what he was seeing
there and people started following him
and they would take his information and
put it into the format and so we ended
up with with 3,000 tweaked tweets from
this translating behavior Oh 1,000 and
then they got retweeted over 3,000 total
but 1,000 are different tweets of people
translating information and so are are
you scenario changed from this idea that
it would be an affected person using it
to this idea that a remote volunteer
could use this sort of human computation
if you guys have learned about that but
it sort of this this human computation
activity where people in the crowd can
process information and so we actually
do some research about these were remote
volunteers but it was very quickly that
we realized that tweak the tweet wasn't
the only thing they were doing it was a
tiny part of this rich digital volunteer
activity of people that were trying to
help out in the remote crowd so when I
see a remote crowd they weren't in Haiti
they were actually all over the world a
lot of them were in french-speaking
Canada but they were people on almost
every continent Australia the people in
the Middle East Europe in the US and and
and they were just working to do a
variety of different things and so for
us tweak the tweet becomes a portal to
this crowd work and my next study that I
did was the study of real focus on
digital volunteers so who were they and
and and how did they come together and
what were they trying to do yes which
years as part of that research did you
get any insight into how the tweet
tweets were then being used within the
crisis response itself so they were they
were being used then over years and
years of deploying this I finally have
attraction where I've heard back now
from a couple FEMA and some other groups
that during some of the hurricanes
they're looking into it now they want
the data in a different format because
they're not allowed to access Google
tools from there
government computers and things like
this and they're not really allowed to
tell people that they're listening to it
because they have all these problems
these government agencies in the US and
other places that have liability issues
have a lot of problems telling the world
that they're going to listen to this new
information source because they don't it
know how they're going to process it and
they don't want to have another 911 991
service open up because they don't have
the capacity to deal with it and so
there's all these organizational issues
so it's just starting to get traction in
that sense and the way that was used in
Haiti was really as a signal by these
digital volunteers that they knew that
they were doing what they were doing but
all I'll talk about that later but it
was really it wasn't used well some of
the information ended up in the Isha
headey platform which ended up on a
crisis map which the amana tarian
responders like we don't know what to do
with it so it it was getting there but
only a tiny bit at that time so we end
up doing an analysis like a we call it
virtual ethnography but we're looking at
all these tweets and from the 340
Twitter's it had almost 300,000 tweets I
didn't read all of them but I read a lot
of them and I did interviews with 19 we
so he identified the 74 and we managed
to contact an interview 19 tweak the
tweet translators and they told us about
what they were doing what they were
trying to do and how they came about how
they came to do it and so here's a quote
from one of those interviews I think
that's when I went on Twitter and
started tweeting then I discovered a
whole bunch of people tweeting for Haiti
I started doing it myself and building
up connections as much as I could in
order to try to save some lives if
possible so for a lot of the respondents
in our study like Twitter was the portal
ER activities they actually they didn't
know that they were going to volunteer
they didn't know what they were going to
do they just had this tool and they were
like well let me let me see how I can
use it and then they would go there and
see other people doing it and then they
would start copying it and they would
and they would try to do this behavior
so what was it that they were doing in
the most basic sense from all of them
almost all of them the first thing they
do and the thing that they do most often
is identify an axe and amplify
actionable information and here's an
example I'm going to use so mark Winne
was on the ground in Haiti so there's a
few people that were tweeting from Haiti
very quickly the crowd identified them
and they start retweeting them it what's
happened here is after about two weeks
after the earthquake this issue of human
trafficking of children became a really
salient in the US media and other way in
other places and so people sort of
paying attention to that so this guy's
reporting that there might be some human
trafficking of children going on and
within about a within an hour 15 people
had retweeted this but with I think
eventually 16 do so very quickly the
crowd and this is 16 of just the people
we identified who were tweek tweek
tweeter it's a tongue twister but who
are using tweak the tweet right so
within that small group we have 16
authors retweeting this information very
quickly and when they told us why were
they doing that well very simply I
wanted to pass around information I
thought was relevant and then this next
one it is actually a little more
interesting I quickly identified the
sources of good information the people
who met well but got tricked by hoaxters
and tricksters and the people actually
in Haiti both locals journalism and aid
workers so the second quote is actually
really important because it shows up
again and again in our research so if
we're thinking about designing to take
advantage of any of these behavior we
see that they're not just trying to
identify good information or information
they think it's good they try to find
people that they think have good
information whether are there on the
ground or somewhere else and they
amplify this this information and it
happens over and over again it's sort of
like it's like the Gateway to digital
volunteerism is the retweeting good
information so the next thing we started
seeing was or the nascent we saw was
that they were routing information to
response organizations and so in this
case we had almost 20 different
instances of this I think even more
we're different we're Twitterers would
see the information and then they would
make a tweet out of it and send it by
putting the account name in their tweets
they would send it to the Red Cross or
two Navy news or Team Rubicon it was a
NGO that had people on the ground in
Haiti so people would find information
and first they would just amplify it and
then they started finding people to send
it to where they could they could try to
connect the information with someone who
could use it and so explaining that
behavior by searching Twitter and
finding these p
we could send them details on where to
go and who needed what for instance if
we saw they were headed to a particular
area so they actually were like so
people in the remote crowd were trying
to find out which NGOs were in which
places find information from people who
had needs in those places and send it to
them using Twitter so they started act
like remote operators in this situation
where there was just not a lot of way to
meet a lot of these needs and the people
on the ground themselves didn't have
good communication tools at the time
another thing they did was verify
information and this is sort of
something that they didn't always start
out doing it pretty soon they realized
gosh I shouldn't just be sending out any
old information or retweeting whatever I
see any of them learned this the hard
way because people called them out on it
but eventually sorted verifying
information and this quote which talks
about verifying actually hope it's big
enough for you guys to see actually
gives a lot of more insight into into
what this digital volunteerism ethic
look that was developing so this
volunteer said crisis tweeting is an art
really so you can see at this point this
is a couple months after the event we
didn't interview him right away we did
we took a couple months figuring it out
she says this activity has been defined
as something she calls it crisis
tweeting it's something that she does it
has a name accuracy can mean the
difference between life and death for
the people directly affected that's why
we ask that people not retweet
information they haven't confirmed so
this is not only saying that she's
learned this lesson like that she's not
going to do it but there's she's
actively shaping the behavior of others
so these digital volunteers start going
out and trying to get other people to do
the right thing shape their behavior so
they're not putting bad information in
the system they're not over amplifying
that information sometimes during Haiti
people would tweet info or urgent needs
and it was several days old people want
to help but don't appreciate that they
may cause harm and so they're reflecting
on these lessons in recounting a lesson
learned and you can see like a structure
for their their work emerging through
these interactions with themselves and
also the constraints of the technology
so we've got this problem that
information gets out of date out of date
so people are retweeting something that
someone needed to be saved but actually
it was four days old and this what might
cause problems with for
spawners going to the wrong places so
the constraints of the technology are
actually wrapped up into the structure
of their work and the rules that they
have that they're developing for how
they do their work and what they do and
I relate this in some of my work to
structuration theory by giddens and/or
makowsky it talks about how this
relationship between technology
struction and act structure in action
another interesting thing was how they
came together this is another quote from
the interviews in the beginning I worked
alone I started recognizing people who
seem to have good info and we would
support each other retweet each other
and help find info for each other and in
fact they all they they they came
together in a very interesting way so
this is just the 74 people that
translated a tweak to tweet and we can
see for people sort of did this in a
vacuum they say they saw the information
they translated they put it out there
but the rest of them if you look at
their tweet streams these connections
aren't friend following relationships
they're actually people talking to each
other through mentions in their tweets
so public that message messages to each
other within the group and and as you
can see it's a pretty tight group and so
and the the line thickness is how much
the conversations were going on between
those two users so we do this we pull
together and say oh there's this there's
this network graph well that's
interesting all the volunteers knew each
other a lot of them did so let me went
back and did an interview with them and
we said how many of these people that
you were talking to did you know before
the haiti earthquake had you talked to
on twitter in real life I don't care
where and three of them had known one
other person in the network of the 19 we
have so you can strap relate through the
math I think it's like 10 or 11 10 or 11
of these connections were probably there
prior to prior to the haiti earthquake
so that what we see is this sort of
emergent organization where when people
come together during in the aftermath of
these events and form an organization
and actually we see some evidence of
that in disasters prior to social
meeting anything else emergent
organizations have often come together
where people start coordinating activity
after disaster events so this maps onto
what we know about disasters as well as
interesting things about social me
there's also this good question maybe I
even with them into this best if you
have any idea how people got sucked into
that that word have a good day what my
as far as I can tell they saw other
people doing it and then they and then
it would identify people that were
sending the information and then they
would say hey I have information for you
okay and then they would it was all sort
of through their activities so when I
imagine it and I guess this is the site
where I talk about it it's like so
during doing the public nature of tweets
and the fact that you can have like non
reciprocal relationships you can
actually connect to people during events
you can send messages to people that
you're not connected to so you can send
messages to whomever you want so there's
an all the activities visible so as you
can see each other at the same time we
see all that that all that
identification activity the retweets the
address tweets the way people mark up
the tweets so a lot of that information
the activity to process the stuff and to
and to move it around actually become
some of these connections you can see
how the tweak the tweet was a marker for
people to be using to be doing the
verifying activity and some other things
a lot of the interviewees said we used
to pick the tweaked it to market to show
people we were potential volunteers or
to show them we were doing the right
thing but then they could see how other
people were doing that negatively could
start connecting to them so they're
digital volunteer activity actually
becomes part of how this structure
emerges and what it looks like which we
think is kind of fascinating I might
have time to talk about it at the end
we'll see and so at the end of this
study I was studying the ball and
tweeters a group of these voluntary ters
a small group of them actually was maybe
10 or 15 moved off and formed their own
organization they actually became an NGO
formal 501 3 non-profit in March of 2010
so just a couple months after the
earthquake with the intention to keep
responding to Haiti and then to respond
to other events as digital volunteers
and they named themselves humanity road
and humanity road has become the focus
of some of my more recent work I went
off in
did went off to my computer and I was a
participant observer of humidity road
for 17 months where I would be with them
trying to help them respond to different
events so I'm going to tell you a little
bit about humanity road and how they
work and what they did but they
basically were a group of volunteers
that branched off they brought in some
new people they lost people over time
and now they are a virtual response
organization that goes from event to
event the event trying to help process
information in different ways and and
they also they have this expanding
organization which also fits the model
of what we've seen in disaster response
before so we've seen organizations that
are expanding I think I would map
humanity road to something like a
digital Red Cross if that makes sense
it's sort of a Red Cross like
organization they expand during events
take on more people and then after
events they sort of contract virtual
organization as I said fiction of a
global workforce so they have people
from from all over the globe working
which is interesting because they can
cover they can cover events that happen
all the time because they have people in
all sorts of time zones they can pass
off work from one to another as they go
volunteers are members of the
organization this is a little different
than that sort of immersion organization
these people for Humanity road they go
through trainings they sign up they get
on a webpage they're formally members of
the organization although they do take
in spontaneous volunteers during events
and try to train them very quickly and
incorporate into them their organization
they have about they have like eight to
ten core members of people that go from
event to event to event then they've got
maybe 15 peripheral members who join
every once in a while and then during
events they can usually get new people
from the affected area but they usually
always say a couple days their mission
statement gives you a good picture of
kind of what they do and what they think
they are who they think they are
humanity's Road mission is to educate
the public before during and after
disasters on how to survive sustain and
reunite with loved ones you can see how
some of this echoes some of the earlier
activities of the digital volunteers
their volunteers are trained and
equipped to use internet and mobile
communications technologies to collect
verify and route information
line during sudden onset disaster so
they did a very good job of identifying
what it was that they were doing as well
and tweeters and trying to sort of
codify that and make that into an
organizational practice using the
internet they provide public safety
information as well as directing the
public to governmental and aid agencies
that are providing assistance for the
disaster so they're trying to connect
themselves to emergency response and
that's actually something they've been
working on they work through a lot of
different platforms that are Lana they
use a lot of different tools so they
will try anything their researchers
dream because they will incorporate your
technology until they realize that it's
holding them back and they do have a lot
of researchers working with them not
just me because they're doing
interesting work in there an interesting
design case they mostly work through
Skype which is like their virtual
offices so they go to work by just you
know logging on to skype seeing what
people are doing Skype is actually where
they coordinate where they train teach
where they organize socialize like
almost everything happens there it
actually gets quite confusing they have
some shown some incidents that where
they've been trying to better organize
using different tools because guide kind
of becomes a mess they use Twitter for a
lot of different reasons they monitor
information it's used for outgoing
messages to tell people what to do they
talk to people that are affected using
Twitter these are for recruiting and
they also use google type documents for
coordinating scheduling things like that
you can see where this sort of echoes
their their mission statement what they
are is there a virtual organization one
of the things that does that they do
that it's interesting as they send out
tweetable which are like these little
package tweets that they have a list of
spreadsheet somewhere so if you're in
humanity road and you want to do some
outgoing message is messaging during an
event you pick up a tweetable and you
send it out and in this way they can
actually control what their volunteers
are messaging so they don't message the
wrong things so basically they try to
tell people when an events going on okay
the waters rise and get out of it you
know these very basic Disaster Response
stuff and it's very similar to what the
Red Cross puts out and some of their
well the Red Cross is tweeting the stuff
to now actually their most used
tweetable is not surprising to me but
this one shows up all the time if you do
analysis on their tweets verify twice
tweet once rumors put lives at risk you
can see this I positioned them sort of
being they see this as at social media
educators like they're out there to now
tell people how to tweak correctly
during responses during disaster events
which is interesting in its own respect
because people can be resist that
messaging as well and one of the most
interesting things they do is they
create these resources where during
events happen women events are happening
they take information from all over the
place they take all the damage reports
all the reports of where the airports
are where the shelters are who are the
people responding this event and they
put it on in a common resource than
anyone can access and so big they
basically synthesizing information in a
way that that that kind of other
activity didn't do where the information
is kind of out there nobody can really
figure out how to use it they're trying
to become a resource for for people that
are affected and government aid and
they're doing a better job over time of
establishing these but event after event
after event they put these out and for
many of them nobody really looks at them
but they're starting to figure out ways
to get to to match this activity to the
needs of responders there's some
interesting questions that are
fascinating for me as I've been
researching them they're constantly
trying to figure out what kind of work
they can do and what kind of work they
should do so they've got all these
issues of capacity so the Red Cross
you've got a large red cross and you've
got these local places and something
happens and the local chapter expands
and responds and then it something
happened somewhere else and that local
chapter expands in response humanity
Road could literally go to seven events
of day depending on where they draw the
line of what events they have so they
say they want to be a global virtual
response group so they could be working
all the time but they have a limited
amount of capacity they have a limited
amount to respond to different events
and so they're constantly negotiating
whether this event is big enough whether
we have the right capacity whether like
for the Libya violence that was
happening before the Revolution or
before the change there I don't exactly
know how to characterize some of those
things they were thinking well should we
respond should we try to help in some
way there or could we do it could we do
damage and things like that so they
they're constantly negotiating this and
it's fascinating to watch here's an
example the bank the Bangkok flooding is
still bad but with language barriers we
haven't had much success in that area of
the world so here we have this virtual
response team all of a sudden they want
to be more official and move from event
they want to tap into to formal response
and yet they're having to work out a lot
of organizational issues of where they
belong what their role is and we've been
trying to kind of trying to figure out
what is their role for a group like this
and they're not the only ones there's
other groups trying to do this in
situations am living with person yes
exactly they want to do very very
actually they absolutely do is one of
the first things they were do before
they actually the two that's two people
that were catalyst for starting the
group had done family reunification
using technology before social media
after about social media was there but
they were using bulletin board
technologies and they were helping
connect people after the hurricane
katrina they had somehow work with Red
Cross to get a van to drive around with
a bunch of equipment so people could get
online and figure out family
reunification so they've always seen
that as part of their goal and they try
to figure out where people are missing
only thing is we've got google person
finder we've got a lot there's a lot of
other technologies out there to that are
doing things like that and so it's
interesting to see where the needs are
because that might not be the biggest
need anymore because we've got other
technologies filling that gap we
actually been seeing them sort of as the
steward of the costumers of the Commons
I don't know if we've if anyone's heard
of Austrians work on governing the
comments but there's this idea that you
know the comments you can't be covered
it all ways to sort of destroy itself
and then ostrom came back and said
there's ways to govern the comments but
you have to do it from within the
commons you can't be like some group and
say okay you've got this space you've
all been functioning and we're going to
put more rules in there and and that
that that's usually unsuccessful but
humidity rose a sort of example of
people that have risen up in this space
and they've trying to enact order within
this space to sort of make it make it
usable and and they have this big
question again of how to connect their
efforts with formal response and they're
working on there now working with the US
Navy
they're working with un ocha in
different places to try to they're doing
exercises together to try to match their
capacities of all this capacity and they
could actually have more capacity if
people knew that they were connected to
if their efforts were actually going to
help and there have these questions of
how to match these crowd capacities to
formal response so way switching the
equation now so I'm going to move away
from this very like studying a few
people doing very specific kinds of work
to step back and look at things from for
the 10,000 foot level and so these are
not in order but in the middle of my
humanity Road study I also did this
study on on the Egypt revolution and we
rewrote a paper how the revolution will
be retweeted and I'm sure many of you
remember these events but very
interesting in 2010 Malcolm Gladwell
pens that New Yorker essay and he says
the revolution will not be tweeted and
then we talked about this during lunch
but I would i'm pretty sure it was
social media sorry we can't we can't say
exactly how much but social media was
definitely used and i'll show you some
statistics to show you that people were
on the ground we're using it but social
media including twitter and facebook
were used during the Arab Spring
revolutions in 2011 in Tunisia Egypt and
then off in other countries as well and
for these mass disruption events we
began to see that similar mass
convergence there's very similar mass
convergence from crises we were
witnessing global participation and we
theorized that that some some global
crowd work was also going on and we
wanted to know what kinds of crowd
worked well we theorize I was working in
some ways and we went and look to see if
they were and we found some things we
didn't expect but we found some things
we did so what we did our methods on
this for these big sets of social media
data if you want to do sort of the
qualitative quantitative analysis we're
doing but we do we do get into the data
sampling and figuring out how you're
going to cut the data and what you're
going to look at is often one of the
most interesting questions but for this
data we had over two million tweets over
300,000 Twitter's and we decided to
focus on information
diffusion as a measure of crowd work so
people spreading retweets and and
spreading information in different ways
and that was informed by our previous
work on on the fact that people identify
an amplifier information when they're
acting as digital volunteers and so what
we did was we identified the most
retweeted Twitter so not we're not
looking to cut we're looking at who the
crowd recommends the most and we
wouldn't determine the location for a
sample of these and we did it
qualitatively where we went through all
their tweets and with an Arab speaker
and English speakers and figured out
whether people were on the ground in
Cairo during the events or not and this
is kind of fascinating button so we took
a thousand most retweeted Twitter so the
people the crowd recommended the most
took a sample of that and we ended up
finding a thirty percent of the most
highly retweeted Twitterers were in
Cairo at the time of the event and I am
certain to say that thirty percent of
all the people Twitter tweeting during
that event we're not in Cairo that I'm
sure of so you can see that the crowd
very at a very basic level is acting as
a filtration center or identification
network to find people on the ground but
gets a little more interesting than that
so again we knew some of this was
happening from from our studies that
showed that the crowd was amplifying and
identifying information coming from the
ground we knew that we conceded the
retweet acts as a recommendation
mechanism but it actually isn't quite as
straightforward as that so we've got
this these two things so people have a
tendency to retweet information that has
a broad appeal like pictures things that
are funny jokes the photograph of the
people getting married in Tahrir Square
was very popular so there's these kinds
of kinds of information that has broad
appeal and then there's a kind of kinds
of information that have local at
utility like we're all going over to
this bridge because the other way has
been blocked when we see some tweets
like that too and so the crowd tweet
tweets geez the crowd treats that
information in different ways god these
a lot of tongue twisters today the crowd
treats that information in different
ways and and one of the interesting
things is that quack at all
identified that there's a gap between
the number of followers and the number
of times a cat account has retweeted so
if you just simply take who's retweeted
than most you get thirty percent you get
some idea and you can get closer but but
it's not it's not the whole equation so
i theorized and i did this using some
tools i had it was pretty simple very
quickly it took me three seconds that
the times retweeted over the initial
number of followers is a pretty good
filter it gets much better than thirty
percent and I'll explain that a little
bit here so we found three things three
things that were interesting there's
actually a few more and we didn't test
but okay so if a person has retweeted a
lot they're more likely to be on the
ground but if a person has a whole bunch
of followers and they retweeted a lot
really doesn't sell as much about
anything but if a person has a has very
few followers during an event and all of
a sudden this event happens and they're
retweeted a lot they're a lot more
likely to be on the ground okay that's
pretty straightforward well the next
part was interesting too and this comes
from our empirical studies so if you
retweeted once a whole bunch so excuse
me if you retreated for one tweet a
whole bunch so I wrote something that
was so funny and a thousand people
retweeted me during this event I'm it
doesn't mean I'm more likely on the
ground but if you're retweeted for a lot
of different things a lot of different
kinds of things over the time of the
event then you must be an interesting
source so maybe you're not have
retweeted a lot maybe only 15 people are
retweeting you but you retweeted for a
whole bunch of different things you're
more likely to be on the ground so we
started seeing like translating some of
our empirical work to some of these
measures that aren't necessarily in a in
a tweet profile like you actually have
to go calculate some of these things and
we're able to come up with a pretty good
way to filter paper people on the ground
we did some machine learning studies on
that with the Occupy protest which
didn't do as well as we hope but showed
some promise as well and so stepping
back a little bit so the different kinds
of studies i'm going to kind of try to
talk about crowd work that we've seen in
a in a broader sense and talk about my
efforts to sort of characterize this and
again some
some resistance the crowd sourcing term
and I have to admit I kept going i went
to crowdsourcing workshops and things
that i had all this research I'm doing
I'm seeing the crowd do all this
interesting stuff and I was at the
workshop like these people aren't
talking about what I'm talking about so
I I try to figure out so where do I fit
within crowdsourcing where does this
kind of work fit within crowdsourcing
and what is this how can we expand our
ideas of what the crowd is capable of so
I want to start out a little bit and
unpack crowdsourcing and and this is
this is a little bit of just it's just
something I've been interested in doing
for a while and I think I finally found
one of the problems that I was having
but so Jeff how poins crowdsourcing in
2006 and he's a journalist we on what we
thought we decided earlier we don't know
why that term caught on better than
other terms except it was snazzier he
writes a book in 2003 on his website he
then posts two different definitions for
crowdsourcing and in one of them he
calls crowdsourcing well he used his
different terms in one he's talking
about crowdsourcing as the act of taking
a job traditionally performed by
designated agent and outsourcing it to
an undefined generally large group of
people so that that definition is
outsourcing in a soundbite version he's
saying the application of open-source
principles to fields outside of software
so it's open source so okay sources in
both of those but the source is very
different source and open source has to
do with open code that source sends for
code source and outsourced is a
workforce that you push up so there's
there's very different ideas and so I
actually put crowdsourcing sort of on a
scale between open source and
outsourcing except when I run into
people that are just talking about it
not nine times out of ten but a lot i
have a class i'm teaching on crowds and
crowdsourcing and i had everyone say
what their definition was and the first
day almost all the definitions look a
lot like outsourcing you think
Mechanical Turk you think of these ideas
where you have this idea you design a
system you break things up into little
parts everybody does their little parts
they put it back together and that's
what you get and that's certainly not a
lot of what I saw though some of the
work that we did does fall on that area
so i imagine crowdsourcing is sort of
this this spectrum between outs open
source
in outsourcing and then some of the work
I've been seeing actually falls off that
scale too I think this emergent
collective behavior which I'm calling
crowd work doesn't necessarily fit and
some of our ideas of crowdsourcing so
what I what I was doing was research
that kind of hit all over this scale we
can see that the the tweak the tweet
translation work kind of was emergent
collective behavior and maybe moving
over towards some open source where
people said hey let's do this and let's
do it this way although there were some
people that were just taking our
instructions that they could do it in
that way and translating it so there was
some sort of micro work activity within
tweak the treat translation you can look
at some of the Egypt Twitter's I didn't
talk closely about this but there was
this case of people who were during the
Egypt event they were propagating a meme
I don't know if anybody see the progress
bar meme did anybody see the progress
for me they kept like doing the progress
bar mean but then switching what it
meant so they were like deep
uninstalling mubarak ninety-nine percent
complete and then was in and say
installing freedom ninety-nine point
nine percent complete and so they were
all like sort of playing off of this and
it was sort of this emergent collective
behavior to show solidarity and then
some of the identifying people on the
ground in retweet and we can kind of see
as collective behavior the volunteers
were definitely this emergent collective
behavior that then moved over maybe into
an open source like community and then I
see humanity road and some other some
other groups have been looking at kind
of move off their open source
communities they come together they
decide they want to do this activity to
kind of figure out their ways and then
they start acting like an outsourcing
outfit where we do this and someone can
ask us to do this and then we'll
complete the test but we're going to
decide how we do it but we'll complete
tasks for you so this sort of difference
between we all kind of define how we do
it to we you give us a task and we'll do
it for you to someone else tells us what
to do and how to do it and and it says
kind of skill Michael you're glad to be
haters situation isn't stable one the
how long can we sustain an undefined
goal I am I see this constant movement
of from the emergent collective
and it's not even it's a constant
movement this way um from other groups
as well including Ushahidi is you see
this kind of tendency to you emerge you
kick the emergent all the time I think
it'll merge again like after you know up
after the Joplin tornado digital
volunteer groups emerged they were
totally knew they had a few people that
might have done other events before they
told me no but but for the groups that
want to put down structure I think as
you put down structure you become more
of these other other types of things and
there's sort of this shift I've seen
this shift to the right I'm bad with my
right left that's really bad for a
former athlete to admit it but
interestingly enough I want to talk a
little bit about who she Katie before I
kind of clean up the talk a little bit
and pull it out because if shaheedi is
the major digital volunteer not the
major but it's one place for a lot of
digital volunteerism that's been
happening in the form of crisis mapping
so after the Haiti earthquake Ushahidi
which was a platform that was developed
in Kenya around reporting ethnic
violence they launched it in the carina
in a crisis sense in combination with an
SMS shortcode so people could send text
messages for free from Haiti with their
needs to a platform then they had a
group of people to translate that from
the creole language to english and then
they had a group of people categorizing
that information trying to map it and
they had these very interesting they
developed a very interesting work
practice where they divided up in groups
this group verifies this group maps this
group categorizes and so we had this
this they brought in initially it was
co-located people at Tufts University
but then they started using a larger
crowd to do it it was basically this
crowd sourced effort to help process
information coming from a graph from the
ground during the haiti earthquake and
in the same sense that was like an
open-source effort there like we had
this platform you can come help me
process it but over time there's been a
group of people who are crisis mappers
who have formed their organization they
go from event to event to event you can
ask them to map you can say oh we need
your help mapping an event they'll take
the uchiha deep lat
and they'll be on skype skype calls
organizing with each other and they will
map your event for you and again there's
this sort of shift into becoming a
having set practices that they do they
organize and other people give them
tasks this isn't a perfect I think we
can come up with exceptions I try to put
a framework down for crowdsourcing it
took me three days I got nowhere that
was as close as I could get um
personally that map's my needs there's
just so many different things I've also
been thinking of crowd work as
collective intelligence how they can I
go or should I should I wrap it up
within as I've good move since you oh ha
rim shot to go 5 and I want to give Lee
Simmons I'll try to wrap it up in three
or four minutes so been thinking of crab
workers collective intelligence I'm
actually been using a digital
distributed cognition view and seeing
want to take you through all of this um
I've been seeing a distributed cognition
holds that cognition is socially
distributed across physical and digital
resources and I've been using this to
see how cognition is is distributed
across the digital volunteers and these
networks that I'm seeing and talking to
Edwin Hutchins he says 20 when he thinks
that he was that came up with this idea
of distributed cognition he says when
you think about it as this question what
information goes where when and in what
form well as i was looking at all this
twitter activity i was seeing ok
representations its transformations of
representations let me unwind net so
seeing all these tweets this is a
representation of information and then I
was seeing these transformations that
were happening in different ways so
different ones of these different
members of the network different nodes
were filtering information recommending
and routing at verifying it and they
were creating new and they were creating
new representations from that that had
different kinds of information in
different formats so they were you know
you could amplify if you that shows you
where it goes and routing it pointed to
other places and then you can format it
so it changes the structure and then you
can see this idea of of these these
networks so if you imagine this is the
digital volunteer network and it's
embedded in a much bigger network and
you've got these nodes that are that are
trying to get information out maybe some
people are amplifying it and all of a
sudden it get
into this network and then the network
lights up because it's good information
like seven people retweet it and then
someone in there sends it off to the Red
Cross you can see this sort of like
cognitive architecture where the
information is moving around so you
think when i think about collective
intelligence like I instantly see these
these tweets moving around and these
these networks acting as sensors for
good information or sensors for for bad
information where they kind of attack it
and the different ways that it happens
and so i want to i'm going to give you a
little story i think i'm going to end it
on that so somewhere last spring i was
hugging humanity road and they wanted to
talk they wanted me to you as a
researcher they're like oh I have a
problem for you I really want to know
what happened in this one instance in
Haiti and I know you have the data and
there was this hospital up in milou
Haiti it is this question in the
backtrack a little bit this question
also speaks to people always ask me
about impact of this work it's very hard
to quantify it's very hard to quantify
how the digital volunteers helped during
Haiti but there was this hospital up in
the northern part of Haiti so the the
earthquake was down in the south and the
roads were all had been severely damaged
it was very hard to get from the south
to the north there were thousands and
thousands of people waiting outside of
medical field hospitals for amputations
and treatment and all sorts of things
and and they just they couldn't get them
fast enough and they were just waiting
for treatment and there was a hospital
milou haiti up in the north that had
capacity for initially 70 but eventually
200 after three days they expended 200
they had capacity and they had no
patience and they sent out they didn't
use Twitter directly they were on
facebook they were on CNN I report they
sent up hundreds and hundreds of emails
and I see these because the information
then showed up on in comments of other
people would write like Anderson Cooper
puts out some bloggers about about Haiti
these people would put it in comments
this information we've got a hospital in
the low it is empty we have 70 beds all
you have to do we have a helicopter pad
we've got all this information so they
put it on social media Twitter picks it
up all these digital volunteers are
putting it out there they're like
here it is and there I find all this
information from tweets that point to it
so I use Twitter to sort of point to the
as a record of what the digital space
looks like with all this information
like we've got this this hospital and
it's open and and so I talked to
humanity road and they said yeah we saw
this and then we sent this tweet to the
US Coast Guard and the next day the
Coast Guard was delivering patients
there and we saw it on on on CNN and
this was like they send out the message
for five or six days that they had a
hospital and it was only later in the in
the week so we took him almost five days
to get patients into the hospital
eventually gets crowded so she won't see
says I want to know if it was my tweak
to the US Coast Guard that that got
patients delivered there and it was the
US Coast Guard bringing them in and I
said pretty sure wasn't but I said I was
like well you know I don't think it
matters because you know your tweet was
out there and they were all these other
tweets and people moving around it was
like collective intelligence and the
thing was moving in it finally the
information finally got ratted to the
right person and she didn't want to hear
that that's not what she wanted to hear
but I went and I said let me let me
really go in the goatse and I didn't
even know that the Twitter had an impact
and I still can't say hundred percent
that did but there were a couple contact
information in the information so the
people were saying we have this facility
please contact carol fit for Tim Tim
trainer here's her phone numbers they're
different contact information show up in
different tweets so I can't I tried to
contact carol fip and Tim trainer and I
finally got on the phone with Tim
trainer who was in Haiti at the time he
was working with the hospital and he
said here's what happened we had this
facility the Red Cross newer they were
there all the NGOs knew they were there
they came they said you're too small we
can't use you we can't get the people up
here sorry and so and so they weren't
being used and so people knew we were on
the mat like the big people knew were on
the map the smaller people didn't and
the US government didn't know what was
going on and they were just trying to
help and so we used social media we
purposefully put the information out
everywhere we could and we don't know
how it happened but eventually the US
Coast Guard emailed Carol fip who was in
all these things we connected and
eventually they was the
eyes filled up they did over 300
amputations they treated over 800
patients they had a huge survival rate
I'm not going to give you numbers
because it breaks my heart when the
other numbers are there but they are
able to treat people and they do credit
social media is making those connections
and I think if you take so if you take
out likes you she made is one who makes
this tweet and I don't know if her
tweets treat makes it but if you take
out all of this activity of all these
people not the people on Twitter because
there are other people taking
information and posting it on to I
reports and other things in other places
all that digital volunteer inactivity
help to make the connection because the
US Coast Guard was not connected with
Carol fit prior to the prior to the
event and and that's sort of the role of
its social media but I see it as this
collective intelligence of helping
information sort of filter and move till
it gets to where it needs to get on
going in future work I plan to continue
to do empirical studies of emerging
ecosystem of vigil volunteerism there's
a lot of different groups it's
interesting watching their structure
emerge and how they're going to figure
out how to work together and I'm also
interested in designing tools to help
support and leverage crowd work i have
this continuing the studies i was doing
with the egypt study is trying to
develop machine learning techniques that
that learn from crowd behavior to help
do things and maybe even learn from more
complex crowd work behavior I'm also
interested in this question shows up
again again is connecting these these
crowd capacities that we've identified
to the emergency humanitarian response
like they have formed they have formal
policies in place and how to how do we
figure out what their needs are and meet
their needs I described it earlier as
all of a sudden they have this whole new
feet of information but they don't know
how to weight that information they're
very used to collecting information in
certain way and knowing okay if I have
this information I respond there but
when it comes through social media there
could be all these other elements that
they don't know including access
including this information and all these
other things so they're trying to figure
out how they wait that information and
finally I'm interested in identifying
other features in capacities and mass
participation and looking at applying
these two other problems and that's it
oh yes acknowledgments I wanted I always
thank my colleagues at
university of colorado especially
professor laisha palin a lot of this
work she's a co-author on and the US
National Science Foundation thank you
Arnie I know a lot of altruism tourism
series digital volunteerism do you know
or are aware of any initiatives to
return kind of like that Coast Guard
example that you just mentioned back to
the contributor's the information about
their country results what they've done
um I know if none I know it's a huge
problem for for the organizations that
are trying to set themselves up and make
connections without the information of
how they have impact very hard to
convince both people they want to serve
as affected people and the
organization's they want to work with
it's hard to figure out how when when
they don't know what their effect is and
it's been very hard to measure their
effect because a lot of it's just it's
happening here we're not on the ground
and in fact I've been talking to more
traditional researchers of traditional
emergency response they always have that
problem it's hard to measure impact
during it in a disaster situation when
your primary concern is not documenting
it your primary concern is helping and
so I think that's that's a big question
is defining ways to measure it and even
when you get to measurement you start to
get to some some awkward things but
we've been really good at identifying
the capacity and the work and very hard
it's been very hard to to measure the
impact and it's a problem for all
digital into your communities as far as
i can tell michael volunteers doesn't
want to come down internet about these
where well you're just retweeting you're
not actually helping they have a
knee-jerk reaction to that day i think
about it so I interviews that I've done
have been with people that are very
intense jessore volunteers people that
were spending during the aftermath of
the haiti earth
you can see from their tweed streams
they're spending 16 hours a day online
doing this activity and they don't think
of themselves as just doing as just
retweeting they they actually they think
of themselves as really impacting things
a lot of them have stories about how
they impacted things that you can kind
of unwind and say when I finally unwind
that Haiti the humidity Road connection
to the melow hospital and in fact their
tweet came after the US Coast Guard
arrived so in fact it did not have any
effect I have not yet told them that but
but so they have they have these ideas
of how they've impacted things and it's
it's hard it's hard to it's hard to
unwind what's going to mean for most of
them they they don't they let Lee Slough
it off like oh yeah but I think we did
this and I'm helping and I have there
are incidences I mean I've been doing
this peripheral II everyone's don't you
know everyone's well over and over again
over two years I've been you know
perfectly involved in this whether it's
through humanity road or running a tweak
the tweet thing and during the Colorado
fires we're online we're trying to help
people are all yelling at each other it
gets really political it gets really
ugly I've never seen anything like it we
should probably do a study on that too
but people start they're all your
evacuated from their houses they're
yelling at the government they're
yelling at each other and this poor guy
was he was getting people were flaming
him and he was like I don't know why
you're doing this just you know why
everybody go somewhere else i'm out of
my house i think it's getting burned
down today and something else and i went
over and I said hey you know what I've
never seen anything like this I've been
a researcher it's just crazy I'm really
sorry for what you're going through and
we ended up having three or four three
or four tweets back and forth and I am
NOT a social worker I'm a computer
scientist okay and here i am like like
counseling even eats like gosh you made
me feel great i'm just going to get
offline and end up losing his house but
he's like this is the best I felt all
day I'm just going to go offline and I
this is going to you know whatever and
you realize that that's what one sort I
know these digital volunteers have
hundreds of stories like that because
they've been doing it over and over
again so there is this impact whether
it's emotional support whether it's you
know I somebody thanked me for helping
them find water after the Christchurch
earthquake because I knew where it was
cuz i was watching everything it's like
oh it's here they asked i was like oh
go to this and you can find it and so
there's these little there's all these
little little things that you can
measure as a volunteer because you're
there you're talking to someone so they
feel good about it but then when the
people that do response in the big scale
was like well you don't have any impact
well it depends on how you measure or
what you think about is impact because I
think they know when they can feel makin
sense that they have they have had
impact whether it small or not they
don't seem to care it's usually like the
attack people have compared to the
impact of a single person voting in an
election yeah that's interesting you
think about it is that I'm thinking
three perspectives but yeah you you can
choose not to but if you choose to and
you think other people are doing it too
then you know that you have a big impact
on a large scale you don't have to know
exactly what your impact is started
touching on this at the end a little bit
but I'm really interested in instances
where where the communications jump
systems so you went from state we to an
actual phone call for somebody call 911
that you have any sense of how where
when why that happens it's it's so hard
to avoid so I've been able to i
contacted tim trainer I've been able to
get Carol fit to answer some emails but
she's never really she seems emotionally
unable to go back to revisit it and I
don't want to she canceled the phone
call we had its hard after the fact to
identify especially this one was two
years ago now so it's really hard to go
under one it's hard for a researcher to
jump I mean I can see okay this
information in almost the same format
was on this comment so i can see that
this tweet was probably made from the
information of that comment or they have
a common source you can sort of trace
these common sources but when it shifts
to a phone call or a private message I
lose the trail so as a researcher it's
hard to do it unless you find the person
the people that made those connections
so that's actually it's almost a
research question it's hard to follow
those connections after a certain point
but it's fascinating to watch them jump
across platforms curious
china answer is always will be
innovation selected action yeah yeah so
there's a couple good studies of the use
of sina weibo is there microblogging
service in china there's a couple good
papers from q at all about sina weibo
and then also some forums in china and
they're seeing the same sort of digital
volunteer he didn't call it that but
communities come together and try to
help in different ways including
matching needs with offers of help which
is a common thing sharing information
passing it around so they have seen some
of those are very empirical studies and
they showed some some impact very
fascinating China just quit out this is
an interesting one from my research kind
of just put out new rules for
volunteerism where they want to measure
it and they want people to have points
according to which groups they volunteer
for how long and it's like they're
totally interchangeable sentence
structure and that's not visible and
here is invest volunteers in general and
with no idea that there that that when
you start putting those kinds of points
to the kind of activity I've been seeing
the people will walk away they're doing
this for to feel good about themselves
to have a public measure of what they
were doing I think would actually cause
them to not want to be a part of it as
it's a very different incentive for why
they do the work and has to do with has
to do with showing people in their
social network that they're doing it
they like the fact that it's public
that's why a lot of the tweet
volunteerism is interesting because you
get social capital of multiple kinds
from from doing that activity because
it's visible but the same time they
don't they wouldn't want to be doing it
from what they wouldn't want that kind
of doing for money or some kind of
points then that would that would
diminish their I don't know the
motivations on this or are fascinating
and I think they're different in this
domain than others but there's
definitely overlap sense of ffxiii also
become another tool manipulation another
important emulation yeah ya know when
you get consent attitudes and I think
about the crowdsourcing and center
each little each little adjustment
really good things like even just how
how the activity works who can see it
and it changes pages why people
participate even across the different
groups who Nettie wrote and the digital
the volunteers their different
incentives for participating one has to
do with making new connections to people
and one has to do with sitting in those
skype chats and having long
relationships with the people that
you're working for now working with
excuse me anyways that's it thank you
thank you
you